make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and uh
a couple things number one patrons uh we
will be doing invincible
part four i think we're covering that'll
be on thursday so that'll be tomorrow uh
the movers are coming today and we kind
of had a super busy day yesterday so i
didn't get a chance to do it for tuesday
but next week it'll go back to being on
tuesday
and a lot of you guys have been asking
why i haven't been covering a bunch of
dc comic stuff
honestly nothing dc comics is making
right now really interests me
um there are a couple things like batman
but for the most part i'm just not
really feeling
any of the stuff that dc is making so if
you guys have any suggestions go ahead
and throw them down in the comments and
i'll go through and take a look
at them because maybe you guys are
reading stories and i'm not but at the
moment it's just like
i don't know man but on the other hand
marvel has more stuff than i can keep up
with so it's not even me being a marvel
fanboy it's just as a comic book fan
that's just kind of where i stand right
so um what this does is this kicks off
the
uh really like the the phoenix saga
story you know for the most part with
regards to jason aaron it's called enter
the phoenix right now
um on the surface when i initially saw
this i was like man i don't know man
another phoenix saga story but i kind of
like the way this is done
right the motivation behind it's pretty
flimsy but i like the way that it's done
right this is really really really
really cool right so in this video we
pick up with dr doom versus captain
america which i think
is a great battle right it's a great
little conflict here so um
the way this picks up is we knew the
phoenix force was basically coming back
and that's one of the things to
understand about jason aaron's comic
book work if you look at this in
isolation
it seems silly but if you look at it in
the the nature of which jason aaron
writes which is
usually building up to a bigger story
then it's just a simple stepping stone
it's really all it is the whole thing
here is captain america is basically
kind of in this place it almost looks
like a forest or like idracil or
something like that
and kind of talking about the nature of
him as a hero right the nature of him as
a character and one of the things that
he lays out here
is that for him he has this kind of
life that he lives where he doesn't
really see himself as being spectacular
and that was one of the things the
things that kind of kept steve rogers
grounded and kind of kept him pretty
normal
it was really understanding his place in
the bigger picture because the reality
is steve rogers is just a guy who can
run really fast and punch really hard
and he's good at battle strategy and
that's essentially it right there really
is
nothing special about captain america
and there are there are a
mountain a veritable mountain of
characters who could overpower and
destroy him with ease
what makes captain america so
significant in marvel comics is the fact
that he is a battle-hardened guy that he
is so good with military strategy the
experience he brings to the table during
his time in world war ii despite having
been frozen for a number of years but
he's the guy who can basically
organize the the superhero community
he's the guy that everybody looks to
when they're trying to figure out what
they need to do when they're facing off
a particular conflict right so
uh captain america's position in the
superhuman community is really more of a
position of respect and ceremony than
than just outright raw power but it's
one of these things where
as soon as you know in the middle of
this whole thing where he's kind of
music and talking to himself suddenly
he's attacked by doctor doom right now
the way that jason aaron writes dr doom
is amazing because i love dr doom as a
character but i have always loved doctor
doom as a character he's not my absolute
favorite
but i've always loved him as a villain
of sorts because he's so arrogant and so
full of hubris that he refers to himself
in the third person
right which is just just downright
arrogance
to not even refer to yourself as me and
just refer to yourself in the third
person right like what's going on guys
this is rob
and rob is going to be talking about
avengers right now here's what rob
thinks when it comes to the avengers
story like it's just it sounds arrogant
right it sounds
funny but it sounds arrogant at the same
time and i love that but at the same
time doom's also one of those guys where
when things pop off
you want him on your side man like you
want you want doom to ally with you
because he just brings
so much to the table but it's one of
these things where he kind of talks
about this nature of the phoenix force
and saying that what he has right now
is a portion of the phoenix forces power
and he's kind of like you know uh this
little fragment this little portion that
you gave me
doom does not do a pair of teeth
you will give me your full totality of
your power right we will end this first
of a tournament it reminds me of the
scene from borat
when uh when he's talking to the chick
and he's just like i will look through
your treasures now
that kind of a thing nonetheless you
know it's basically dr dim has received
a portion of the phoenix's power and is
going toe-to-toe with captain america
right and the idea is to take
you know or to eliminate captain america
and in the tournament now we don't
really know
the basis behind this tournament we
don't really know why it's happening
we'll find out here in a second uh we
just simply know
that seemingly for dr doom killing off
uh steve rogers is the only way for him
to attain the full totality of the
phoenix's powers the problem with this
is captain america hits him with a
shield and when the shield comes back
the phoenix force has been imbued to
captain america right so we just took it
off of dr doom like that now
again there's some stuff going on here
that we haven't really seen before
we haven't really seen the phoenix force
change possession like that right to
change
from you know use an inanimate object as
a vector between itself and a host
usually the phoenix just
bonds itself to a person and that's
basically yet right i mean even when you
had avengers versus x-men and you had
the phoenix 5 it worked the same way
right
branded iron man basically screwed up
the phoenix force and split it into five
separate pieces but it still
bonded to individuals and so it's really
really cool and interesting the way this
is done because steve rogers as a host
for the phoenix
looks amazing and that's what's so cool
is because this is just kind of another
notch in the belt of captain america
captain america has had the cosmic cube
he's used it on more than one occasion
he had the infinity gauntlet we saw that
during the events of
john of the pikmin's avengers and new
avengers like the greatest comic book
story ever told
is one of these things where captain
america has done all kinds of stuff he's
lifted the hammer of thor he's
controlled the casket of ancient winners
we've seen him do all kinds of things
right and so this is just kind of
another notch in the belt of steve
rogers now what we end up doing is
jumping back to an earlier point in time
and then this is when we really get our
explanation in terms of what's going on
here
and the idea is that basically just
outside of avengers mansion a volcano is
essentially emerged and the phoenix
force is inhabiting this volcano and so
when the question of the avengers is how
in the world did this thing this thing
get here right like
what in the world is going on that you
basically end up having a
name with a submariner who just kind of
pops out of nowhere and it's just like
i'm the one who did this right like i am
the one
who summoned the phoenix to earth and it
really seems to be in a lot of ways a
simple vendetta which is getting rid of
the surface world
for neymar it's a lot deeper than that
because the surface world has in a lot
of ways been the cause of
and the source of a lot of problems and
the atlantean will write pollution
different things like that and so is the
desire to just get rid of the surface
dwellers and so we effectively summon
the phoenix to earth and then it's going
to bond with it in order to attain the
phoenix's power
and just wipe out the wipe out all
humans across the surface the problem is
that as soon as he gets there he's
immediately met by wolverine now an
important thing to understand is
wolverine was sent here by the x-men and
the reason why is because we know just
from marvel's publication history the
x-men have an exceedingly close tie with
the phoenix now those of you guys who
are new to comics and you don't really
know what that means
the important thing to really just grasp
out of this is that jean grey
was the first real earth-based human to
become a host for the phoenix more
recently marvel's changed that and they
established that there were actually
other people before jean grey who were a
host for the phoenix force but even with
that being the case
jean grey was the first person to ever
use the full totality of the phoenix's
power and then actually become a villain
while she had the phoenix's power that
was the whole idea behind the dark
phoenix storyline she essentially went
crazy
and uh ultimately ended up becoming a
bad guy and so the x-men's history with
the phoenix force
is very very strong because then you
have rachel summers who's the the
daughter of jean grey and cyclops from
an alternate reality who was a host for
the phoenix emma frost who was the
leader of the x-men at one point had
possession of the phoenix force and so
it's one of these things where the
phoenix is just
almost intertwined with the mutant
population uh inexorably right there's
just no real way to to eliminate that
kind of relationship there and so
wherever whenever the phoenix shows up
on earth the x-men are not far behind
right so that's one of the things to
understand
if you ever see the phoenix in the
marvel cinematic universe if the mutant
population has not been established by
then
it will very very soon right i think
that you'll see mutants established
before the phoenix force but that's just
really kind of how those things work
right and so
it's it's kind of crazy because you sort
of jump back to the the moment with
captain america
and doctor doom fighting each other and
captain america in possession of the
phoenix's power
and then in turn doom having his
possession of the the phoenix's power
really just kind of go toe-to-toe and
start battling each other now as you
would expect because doctor doom is so
capable and because the phoenix forces
abilities basically just augment
his own powers that he goes to kill
captain america the problem is it
doesn't work
right like he does it just it does not
successfully work every time he tries to
kill captain america captain america's
willpower keeps him alive and it's
really just done by way of the fact that
captain america's his willpower is kind
of the main focus of his character right
his desire to always win
so like he always gets back up he
refuses to just kind of acquiesce
and quit and so because it doesn't
necessarily seem to be a battle to the
death so much as a
a battle that will determine whose
willpower is stronger right and so it's
a really cool moment when that happens
because you literally have steve rogers
where he's just kind of being pummeled
over and over and over again and sends
out this psychic projection of his
younger self right when he was very
small
very scrawny and in the end that's
really where his willpower comes from
right the fact that
even when he was a guy that couldn't do
anything to anybody and was in
probably his weakest form he would still
keep fighting right it's his conviction
his courage his strength of character
that's what makes steve rogers who he is
doctor doom lacks that right doctor doom
has conviction but dr doom's willingness
to go the limits
is only contingent based on whether or
not he gains a personal benefit to
something he doesn't fight for anybody
but himself right that's really kind of
how doctor doom works
and so once he realizes that steve
rogers will always be resurrected and
the phoenix force will never let him die
and then he's just kind of like okay
fine then i acquiesce right i quit
like doom forfeits this thing and
ultimately doom is whisked away now kind
of jumping back to the current moment
and getting a bit of a of a full-on
and really more tangible explanation
here that you end up having you know
again this kind of revelation given by
neymar wolverine and neymar sort of
fight for a little while the rest of the
avengers show up and face off against
the forces of namor from atlantis and
then suddenly the phoenix emerges right
the phoenix finally just sort of
appears and then descends down and then
ultimately ends up just kind of
basking everybody in the area in the
glow of its power and then just starts
snatching people away right so
t'challa neymar the submariner uh thor
right carol danvers captain america just
all these various people who were here
and seemingly other people in different
parts of the world and so again that's
where things are kind of bonkers it's a
cool moment and it's awesome to really
see that to see that take place and so
following the defeat or really the
acquiescence of doctor doom kind of
forfeiting in this
and then giving up seemingly captain
america is transported back to the white
hot room now we don't actually know if
that's where he's at but it looks like
that's where he's at those of you guys
who are new to comics the white hot room
is is one of these things where it's
kind of depicted and explained in
different ways in marvel comics the most
common explanation that comic book fans
go with
is that it is at the center of the imran
crystal which is basically this crystal
that's kind of like a gateway to the
multiverse right so if you were to enter
the imran crystal it would be like
walking through a hallway of doors and
you could access any multiverse by going
through the crystal uh if you were to
like
destroy one of the doors quote unquote
or destroy the access point to that that
universe it would actually start sucking
that universe in and it would basically
lead to that universe's destruction
right so
destroying a door in the hallway of
doors that makes up the imran crystal
would lead to the destruction of a
universe
destroy enough of those or fracture the
imcron crystal and you'll destroy the
multiverse right the the impront crystal
will quite literally turn into
a multiversal black hole and start
sucking everything in and then
ultimately it'll create a new big bang
and everything will be born again but
regardless of how you slice it the white
hot room is basically just where those
individuals who are either possessed by
the phoenix and are using the full
totality of its power
or being held by the phoenix end up
residing right so again we're just kind
of assuming that's the case we're not
given a definitive explanation but
because of the fact that captain america
is the one who arrives back here
seemingly captain america won right
you've got jennifer walters she-hulk
you've got wolverine and you've got
t'challa who are here
of course you also have neymar the
submariner and then you have several
other people and that's what's so cool
is it basically shows us there's a ton
of people who are here right you've got
luke cage you got howard the duck which
is awesome you've got hyperion which by
the way when hyperion gets the phoenix
force
it looks amazing look it it's it's it's
stupidly cool but you've got uh you've
got moon girl and devil dinosaur which i
love moon girl and devil dinosaur and
then you got man thing right so like you
got black knight you got a whole host of
characters here shang chi
that kind of a thing right you got a
bunch of folks going on here so
ultimately
these guys are the ones participating in
this tournament and seemingly it will
just kind of continue to bounce around
until ultimately a victor is formed so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end if you guys are new
here to comments explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you